You want to take on mitosis?
Let me get your diagnosis;
It says you're half the man I am
And all your raps are necrosis!
Yeah, I am so perfectly perfect
In all my careful divisions
Creating identical versions
While you are like "Oh I'm so different!"
Don't talk to me >:c
You've been around the block too many times
And your duplicate splitting is
Constantly spitting out
FOUR daughter nuclei?
Don't be jealous 'cause I am sexy,
And I got 2 sets of phases
I like to mix DNA up
When I'm entering my pro-phase stages!
You're like your parents kid;
Just like a clone.
You see this chromosomal genetic
combination's my own!
I'm independent
My chromosomes don't need any pairs
At the end there's only 23
So your mom and dad can share and make
LIFE! Yeah, I'm the one that
Gives you your offspring
Though my genetic variance
can create arrogance
DNA's changing from New York to Beijing.
Sure, if it weren't for you
I wouldn't have kids
But if I wasn't here
THEN YOU WOULDN'T EXIST!
And those babies you keep bringing up?
Aww, real cute!
I'm the one that makes them grow
So you can stop CLEANING THEIR PUKE!
You're like telophase;
The only thing that's worth admiring
is your cleavage
I don't want to give half of my chromosomes up, what I've built in my nucleus is my achievement.
I'm like telophase too, I like to kick back and unwind
But I'm secretly Anaphase
Pulling you apart from inside!
I repair the whole body
to make you grow big and strong
If I wanted sex cells
I would just ask your mom
Hey! Here's a question,
Maybe you have the answer?
Did you know you're the main cause
FOR A WHOLE BUNCH OF CANCERS?
Yeah, your errors cause a LOT of conditions